hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I am your host
Walter for nazy AK and today we are
talking about Superman
doomsday the 2007 animated movie and
it's also the first in the DC Universe
animated original movies and we got some
great people to talk about it right here
but before I introduce them I want to
thank you guys for watching our
injustice debates last week that was
great right yeah may you know that the
winner totally deserved it I wasn't
expecting that either you know but just
happened would you like to see more of
that kind of stuff let us know in the
comments below also keep giving us
suggestions on our vs. series we have a
couple ideas for what we want to do next
but I want to hear what you guys want we
had a lot of really good suggestions in
the back girl versus Robin debate
there's a lot of really good suggestions
so keep giving us more on those and
we'll try to put one of those out for
you guys also as always like the new
Facebook page it's facebook.com slash
awesome comics show port review of arrow
season 4 is up there exclusively on the
Facebook page also an entire extra round
from our Batgirl versus Robin episode is
still available on that Facebook page
extra content always going up on their
pictures reviews etc always on my
Facebook page so go like it right now
okay so I'm gonna introduce you guys now
we'll go with mr. Porter first he's got
the Irish hat he's got the Justice
League shirt you know him I know him mr.
Brian Porter yes so how's it feel good
happy fourth of July man happy fourth of
July to you yeah into the country yeah
end of the country United States of
America this I know we have some
international watchers it's you know
this is a big deal here in America and
we have as always Masana wait how's it
going I have a great aunt is a happy
birthday happy birthday it's all the
Firecracker baby though yeah okay
America everybody
and we know besides Captain America
who's like the most American superhero
it's Superman right
I mean I think we can all agree on that
all-american boy scout all-american boy
scout Kryptonian guy totally he's not
even born in America okay so we're gonna
be talking about this movie we're gonna
go positives first Ayanna what'd you
think of this upon this rewatch or this
first time you saw I thought I thought
before but I wiped all memory of it I
guess so it was at least like watching
it like new and I loved it it's a really
really good animated film it's really
good as Superman film action-packed
you're an animated really really well
done I love all the voice actors in it
we'll get into that later but overall
loved it okay work yeah that was pretty
good too loved the animation style very
Bruce Timm you know oh yeah I like that
so they're still like towards the
original animation styles for DC
animation which is great voice actors
were pretty good like he said I like the
general tone of the movie I thought it
was good flowed well it was a you know
very iconic storyline definitely so they
had to change some stuff but like I
thought it worked really well and as a
starting point for the you know DC
Animated universe it's really good it's
a good place to start I think yeah I
mean I mean oh I know people are gonna
say you know it's not the DC animated we
know it's it's not the Bruce Timm we're
not talking about that we're talking
about this is the first in the line of
the original movies that they've come
out with and this was in 2007 so this is
it's been going for almost 10 years now
with these these movies and a lot of
them really good and this was a really
good starting point I agree yeah my
thoughts on it I yeah I still think that
this is one of the better DC animated
movies it's still in the top ten for me
like towards the bottom of the top ten
but still in there I mean this is still
a really good self-contained story like
Porter said it doesn't bring in
everything from the death of Superman
death and return of Superman because you
can't do that in 70 minutes there's no
way there's so many characters and all
this crazy stuff that happens with that
storyline but as a self-contained movie
if someone just watching it maybe wasn't
that familiar with the death and return
of Superman it's definitely really
enjoyable the fighter oh man
the doomsday fight is incredible the
animation style I really like and just
how everything moves is really really
well done the action is just like I'm
not sure if there's there's got to be a
couple other ones that have better
maybe I can't think of any offhand right
now but in terms of a big just
superhuman fight this one is top notch I
mean it's the quality of this fight
where they they fight inside of
Metropolis and everything with doomsday
in Superman and later Superman vs
Superman it was not bad either but I
think that's one of the biggest and best
qualities of this movie is the action
absolutely 100% for sure for you guys I
will be talking about the voice actors
but we had Adam Baldwin play Superman
here I liked him I liked him a lot
he's a good he's a good voice actor in
general so I liked him okay he sounded
good and he had a decent good or a
decently nice Superman tone to him but I
kept on hearing James like it was okay
yeah but it was hard to separate after a
little while I got into it is fine but
like you know it's just the hero of
Canton keeps playing in my head yeah
with me with Toyman oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I couldn't unhear bender my play
date creepy is Lois fine actually I I
know you don't really like her she
sounded really weird like mation a lot
though actually the character model was
cool ya look good
I'm like well I'm sorry I what
Superman's face that was the one I
wanted I think it was they wanted to
differentiate him from the Superman
animated and Justice League think so
they they put a little more detail and
they gave him that those weird
cheekbones oh yeah I was like I don't
know if it was supposed to be his nasal
labial folds that are like oh really
define yeah he should
it's not that big but within Haitian I
don't really like her as an actor person
whatever she was okay in this but I
don't like her as a person like I just
don't really like the only the only
thing that she was ever good in was the
90s gem volcano and that was just
perfect film in all respects Thank You
Tommy Lee for that amazingness but other
than that I wasn't really a fan of her
but James Marsters spike and Lex I think
he was the best of the characters I
thought he had a really good gravitas
and his character motto was cool he was
a little bit skinnier than the versions
that we usually see but he did great as
him you know I thought it worked really
well so it was weird it was I could
still hear spike in there I couldn't
place it at first because I was very
confused America I was like you have to
play Brainiac at Smallville - yeah yeah
he's been kind of all over the place and
in terms of DC Animated villains
alright villains in general I should say
yeah I went off the tracks any other
like big things you really liked about
the movie you guys again like the action
sequences I really liked there was the
specific like with doomsday fight of him
smashing Superman into like that Boulder
was like really like palpable sequence I
really like that and the he lifted him
by the jaw yes the rule on right though
that was an amazing action in general it
was it was great at one point doomsday
powerbomb Superman so I know there's
some wrestling fan or just a little
power I really liked it when he's on the
bridge and they start firing at him and
they the tank shoots the you know the
big missile I don't we just punches it
punch it yeah just flies right through
it I was like there's a couple moments
like that worse things slow down for a
quick second when the ship ran sponge
again maybe like it goes really fast and
really you know get a couple emotion
frames in there I was like what part in
it too when jews like hits the building
and then the floors all crashed down
that whole little sequence that reminded
me of did you guys ever play rampage
yeah in general sort of reminded me of
in a rampage who's a lot of like
throwing stuff and like people running
around right okay we'll go on to the
negatives here I think that a lot of
people who are comic-book purists will
complain about the the lack of content a
cat well yeah like from like I said
before about the death and return of
Superman there's so many different
things that they could have put in and
in the audio commentary Bruce Timm talks
about you know we only had 70 minutes to
do this and this is the first one I mean
since they've they're doing obviously
Killing Joke which we were so looking
forward to if they've done a two part
for Dark Knight Returns I think if they
did redo this now or if they waited to
do this to later they would probably do
like a two part being like a death and
return of Superman part 1 part 2 kind of
absolutely I would love to see that if
they ever you know would go back to this
but I don't think they will they already
treaded territory with this and they
have more comics to adapt still so I
don't think that's gonna happen but I
would totally be down to see something
like that a bigger scale thing yeah so
maybe that's a little bit of a negative
even get to see superb or the eradicate
Eradicator side work Superman but still
some some cool stuff as a self-contained
story any any big negatives besides and
he's just Louis for you Porter
not really sometimes the animation
flowed a little strangely like I think
in certain scenes damage didn't float a
little weird but for the most part I
liked it I didn't really have too much
to say about it like negative wise yeah
I just Louis pretty much for me I was
like the one part that was really like
Laurel but in a good way is the part
when the clone Superman goes to the
salon and he's sitting in there and he
looks in the mirror and he like sees
through like everything and then sees
the little like blood tonight ball in
his brain and the Blazers it
gradually here going to oh so disturbing
Superman he was a safe metropolis right
yeah could you he digs into his own
brain a pair of scissors well but he he
uses the mirror to lay milk melt it
through and then just takes it out with
like yeah she's melting his own brain
yeah can you can you function like that
well I'm sure he may be like had like a
lazy eye for 10 minutes I know he can
regenerate brain cells but like as it's
happening shouldn't have been like he
gets to it's like I thought that should
have happened but I mean it wasn't the
only okay so to piggyback off your
lowest thing the only scene I thought
really didn't work for me was when Lois
went to see ma Kent
Martha yes Martha went to go see Martha
Kent and that it that scene seemed
really really forced like she like balls
out on her doorstep to be buffed by him
oh and then the whole scene I thought
didn't work very well but that's the
only real negative I think I didn't like
that they were able to like throw it
back at the end with the I know you're
Clark know she like call your mom no
that's cool i I think it was good that
she went to see her and like she's
looking for someone to connect with
totally makes sense but I just thought
the scene in particular the way it was
set up it didn't work
there were small attention to detail
that I really liked to like that Kevin
Smith cameo yes that was so funny I love
that Kevin Smith camera and that calls
back to his writing on Superman lives I
mean the giant spider thing yeah if you
guys know if you guys haven't seen that
go watch an evening with Kevin Smith he
talks about how he wrote his time I'm
writing Superman lives the Nicolas Cage
Tim Burton movie I didn't come out you
can also check out the death of Superman
lives what happened by Jon Schnepp I
donated to by the way and still gotten I
still haven't gotten all my rewards
there mr. Schnapper that was like years
ago man maybe you should send me the
stuff you owe me I don't know thanks pal
but anyway yeah that was a that's a
really interesting documentary though so
go pick that up
has more about that and Kevin Smith's
interviewed and stuff and he goes into
how about that but that was this really
cool little subtle like oh we're gonna
have him fight a giant spider lame that
was really I like that I agree I really
liked that fight scene with Lex and
Superman in the Red Room in general and
even the whole like him feeling so safe
in that room that's stupid though he
comes with room turns on the red the red
the red kryptonite raised or whatever or
the red sun rays and he's got the
Kryptonite knuckles he's like come to
Papa and he's like outside yeah the
obviously not going to go in their ways
and I was just like yeah yeah I like it
right so I wanted to compare this a
little bit to the death and return of
Superman comic so I brought that here
I'll talk about even detail a little bit
more when we talk about pic of the week
but like we said before there's there's
a lot of stuff in here that's not in the
movie and I know people who love this
would be upset that it's not in the film
adaptation of it so the death in return
of Superman is one of the most iconic
huge stories of the 1990s I mean
Superman was one of the first big
characters of died in comics and then
come back later and that sort of opened
the gate for all these other characters
to die and come back
check out max landis is Superman death
and return of Superman
a mini-documentary thing I don't know
what you even call that yeah short-film
thing he did that was awesome yeah that
was really cool so I could check that
out for for more details on it and
comparisons but yeah there's there's a
lot of characters from the DC Universe
and actually fight doomsday first before
Superman does in the comic Booster Gold
and Lou beetle Blue Beetle like a ton of
Guy Gardner right guy Gardner a ton of
people go after him first and they all
get either killed or mangled or whatever
before Superman takes a shot at doomsday
so all that's missing the the return of
Superman which they also handle in here
like I said I mean there's all these
pretenders that come out cyborg superman
i remember picking up the cyborg
superman comic in the 90s i remember
actually getting that I should have
brought but it's a really cool cover
that's cut out and you open it and then
there's cyborg the Superman logo and you
open it and it's half robot Superman you
know he looks like
yeah it's that was crazy they have
Superboy which is a clone of Superman
which they later
you know retcon whatever you Connor Kent
which is right now and the Eradicator
which is like a robot
Superman who came comes alive when
Superman is dead to protect it's very
strange some people love it some people
hate it but that is missing from this
and like I said before I would I would
love to see a two-part figure arc on
this to properly do it one day maybe
they won't do it but it will be
interesting nonetheless to see yeah I
think for a movie that specifically
called itself Superman doomsday you
weren't really expecting the death and
return it was more doomsday thing going
into it and he's really only in it for
like he's in the beginning in it right
but I think I think people always
associate doomsday with the death of
Superman no sorry that's true yeah it's
still one of the actually the highest
like grossing DVDs that they've sold it
might I have to double check but it
might be still like the top one it was
for a long time I'm not sure if it's
been surpassed in that but um so people
still respond to like the death of
Superman even all these years later it's
very funny you know right regardless of
what medium you see it in its gonna be
iconic for a long time yeah absolutely
so I want to talk to you guys about
where this ranks for you in terms of
like the DC anime and movies we've all
seen a pretty DS
amount of these so where does this rank
for you guys for me it's like near the
bottom of the top ten but still in the
time I would I would I would agree with
that
not my favorite by any means but it's
still really really well done
specifically because of the action
sequences and how they're able to do
that
story-wise it's not as like heavy weight
like plot I would say I mean it's a
whore emotion as much like kind of like
with under the hood but the action
sequences are fairly well done yeah
that's a good cast it's a really good
cast I like listening to my favorite
peeps I like Perry White
yeah he's actually Commissioner Gordon
yeah yeah I like him and a lot of things
yeah thank I like him and was that
reapered yeah Weber yeah he was uh
what's-her-name's dish we Robin
Scherbatsky he's dead and it's how I Met
Your Mother
yeah he's great I like that one line was
like who's that guy in black I'm like
who cares did you kick the crap out of
Superman Oh everybody's gonna look at
him like that's the thing that's when he
comes back he has long hair in the 90s
it's not quite a mullet almost it's
almost 90s more you know it's like it's
enough well
Nightwing headed right Ben Riley Heil
Rainer have it at some point maybe no I
don't think so I know Ben Riley had AI
needs a mullet man it was yeah awful
yeah so yeah I would I think we all
agree this is one of the better ones
yeah it's more towards the bottom for me
too I have to really think of the top
ten yeah yeah but you know one of the
big one of the big things for for me is
the animation because I really didn't
really new animation styles like
flashpoint to me was one of the hey
bring it I
flashpoints animations that was awful I
could not stand a lot of people love
them and it's just like we don't need an
anime for these comics like the art
styles of these comics are so good and
so unique and I know they're hard to
translate on a screen if you can do it
as best you can I think would be
well-received just like they're doing
with Bolin's art for a killing job right
couldn't quite do it 100% so he chose an
artist who was similar and they kind of
gave it its own tone but it's still very
reminiscent yeah
bowling so like if you were to do that
for these comics I think it would do
better so but even with booths Tim's
style its iconic it's you know what we
all grew up on it's a little bit more
detailed of Bruce Timm style it is it's
he's still in there but it's a little
more detailed a little more yeah just a
little more a couple more like lines or
drawn you can see yeah so yeah in the
face there we loved it I'm sorry sure
people love it yeah well okay so pic of
the week is the death of Superman
so this is a one highest-selling if not
the highest selling graphic novel like
of all time it came out obviously as
single issues first but then after it
came out in Drabek form or paper tray
pack form it yeah people people bought
this hate this thing off it was and he
was mainstream news when Superman died
like this was a big deal back in the 90s
so yeah this is I mean just as a a
historical book it's a good thing for
someone who's into comics to go ahead
and check out it's not expensive it's
it's old mine's got like camera where I
bought it but it's got like a bunch of
like like water damage I don't know how
that happened but this one goes up
through the death of Superman so this
isn't the return of Superman there's an
omnibus I think of all that stuff you
could check out those things are huge
yeah but then has like every issue of
him coming back and all the different
characters are trying to take his place
that's all in there so if you're
interested in seeing and reading some of
that stuff go ahead and check this out
and if not if you just want to watch the
movie like a more succinct little
version go ahead and check out Superman
doomsday it is well worth your time
I think most people will enjoy it okay
so guys social medias we all have
accounts Ayano where can we find you
Facebook Twitter
I got an Instagram out there too some of
you know some if you already follow me
if you don't you can if you want to you
don't have to border Facebook was it
facebook.com slash awesome totally
forgot
find me on there posted some stuff on
there I should I really should get some
stuff up on there
as for me I'm always on Twitter I had
awesome underscore Walter I've been
posting a lot about the Power Rangers
movie lately
Bryan Cranston is or Don that's gonna be
interesting the poster came out I don't
have no idea what to think about that so
uh so follow me on there if you're right
I definitely yeah definitely oh yeah I
keep go ahead and follow me on there
also make sure like the Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome comic show
check that out exclusive stuff always
going up in there all the time
and give us suggestions on what DC
animated movie wants to cover next we're
gonna do our best this is a long term
project we're gonna do our best to get
through all of these so what one do you
want to see us cover next I'm sure maybe
flashpoint paradox we could talk about
our problems then I actually like the
movie a lot it's just I'm not a
victorious good that's just me okay so
until next week I want to thank you guys
for joining us today and I want
you for watching and until next week I'm
Walter Bernays yak and we will see you
on the next page happy fourth of July
you